Thanks I'm really it's a great pleasure
to be here this is a wordle if you don't
know what Wordle is rural calm allows
you to take your text an entire paper or
even a book copy it and stick it into a
little box and then it produces a you
know it produces a word list where the
where the most frequent words are the
largest and it produces them at random
in different colors and and so that
that's the wordl of a paper becoming an
awesome so it's actually fun and you can
summarize the entire top just like that
as if just the frequency of the word was
the thing that mattered I say just a few
words about what interests me in world
of oral history then I'll say a few
words about the two projects that are at
least cognate through oral history I've
been involved in and then say a couple
words about its student mind and then
basically open up for discussion I see
that Mary Marshall carcass arrived
that's okay I think you know where I'm
going to say anyway well you don't get I
don't know what to say but within a
realm of domains and things said you do
then so I'm a in this world on the
historical sociologist and have always
been interested in in understanding
historical phenomenon and making sense
of them and I and I'm especially been
interested in trying to develop a
framework with within my discipline
sociology for for understanding how to
make sense of people's actions in the
world typically in my discipline the
strategy that we use to develop causal
explanations or to develop explanations
of historical outcomes relations of
anything is that we observe some action
in the world someone joins a riot
someone participates in a movement
someone engages in a solid heuristic
action of some sort and and and we then
look back to the social structural
position a person their class their
ethnicity where they own land the
attributes that they have so we try to
capture something about them from the
characteristics that they have and and
and then we impute motive well if we
observe characteristics of people and we
observe their action and we bridge that
gap to the imputation of motive who said
well people do that because it's in
their interest to do that so a classical
sociological account of the nazi seizure
of power for example would focus on the
fact that the early Nazis were young
dispossessed on the one hand and petty
bourgeois on the other hand and the
classical sociological understanding of
why people join the not-see party just
to pick one outcome would be that for
the petty bourgeoisie it was in there
the Nazi somehow had an ideological
program against against socialism
against liberal democracy that appealed
to the petty bourgeoisie they thought
they could realize their interests by
support of this party and so we that's
how we tend to make explanations and
that's that's a strategy that's
unsatisfying to me or he's been
unsatisfying to me for a long long time
and what I was always interested in
doing is understanding how to how to
make explanations and work on another
foundation which was people's sense of
self their sense of identity and social
network analysis as a way of thinking
about the world it's a way of thinking
about how our identities of actors in
the world as people who have it the
world are shaped by the source are
shaped by the social relations with a
portent pattern so necessarily if I'm if
I'm indebted in a population of people
who have no sense of self is that there
is that their their sense of self is
associated with a set of practices and
beliefs that that they can recognize
themselves as a member of a group or a
kinship group or a clan or something
that that sense of identity is provides
the springs for action so my work
historically has been on trying to
understand how I could measure the
sources of relations around the person
and then think about how those relations
shape their identity their self
consciously he'll die down and then try
to explain action that I could observe
subsequently and that's another
foundation for historical sociology
that's more similar to oral history I
think it's more similar to try to
understand
and phenomenological experiences of
people and it and it doesn't have to be
historical it can also be on the graphic
it's the ethnographic project is to
understand how people come to see the
world experience the world in that act
in so that that's been a an interest of
mine and um and and out of that interest
groans another interest which which is a
little harder to describe but I've
become I became interested in the fact
that people's understandings of
themselves I involve a involve a
theoretical enterprise that is their
theory and how they got to where they
are now that theoretical understanding
of themselves that's reported and
narrative is actually something that
sociologists can really study in oral
and storage good stuff so when I think
of somebody telling a lie for history
what I'm really understanding is that
you're doing what you know what we do
when we tell the life histories we stand
at some point in the present and and
under some theory inchoate or not under
some theory we search into the infinite
past for events and experiences that
have made us get to the present and then
we array those events and experiences
into a narrative that that is in plot it
in some way that that sounds believable
to awesome and if we're trying to
convince other people it sounds
believable to them but this the past is
a vast sea of experiences so how to
select the events in the past to array
to get you to the future requires a
theoretical orientation even if we don't
think about it as a theoretical even we
don't think about people as theorists we
recognize that they're doing what theory
does which is to tell you what not to
look at so when you think when you're
and you have a theory of something you
know that i don't have to i can deny
some data because it's not relevant to
the problem and by denying some data you
are able to see what elements can't use
to produce scenario so all history to me
is this project that people well the
life story component of oral history is
a project of trying to understand how
people when they come to tell their life
story get to where they are is for me
the project is not understanding the
history for sailors understanding of the
fewer I'm interested in what's the
theory that I've got them there how how
do people tell stories and that with the
idea that we might actually learn
something it could that could be
revelatory of the world in the past but
doesn't need to be but we could learn
something about about these people that
they made themselves not know which is
revealed in the theory that they use the
colorsource so this work is all about
trying to try to understand from life
stories what what the coming process is
how people become something and and take
seriously their own accounts about
becoming so that's what interests me is
I oral destroying is not or as a
sociologist is not how to use history
oral history to tell me something about
the past but how to use oral history to
understand how people theorize how they
become what they are if that's what they
do when they tell us about it and the
model for me it's been a couple of
important and a couple of foreign
sources why is prop which I think you're
familiar
but crop is in this book on fairy tales
studies the structure of fairy tale he
reveals that a fairy tale has a as a
absolutely common morphological
structure that it's 31 or 29 I can't
remember how many elements in this book
and then he rated some fixed number of
elements that are always in the same
sequence and that tells us the reader
that's it that's the genre of the fairy
tale we know it's a fairy tale because
it has those elements in that
morphological structure in the and then
it doesn't matter what fills the fairy
tale so that's the beauty of the props
understanding is that in a particular
place morphologically in this sequence
of these elements it doesn't matter it
if there's a frog or queen toad lizard
of Caterpillar it doesn't matter what it
is some things there that's going to
that is going to act or do something so
so the content of the story becomes
extractable from its form so that's one
major source that our influence on me
and people who are usually influenced by
things like that are called
structuralism that is they're interested
in the structure that then gets
populated by contents and they say well
content is somewhat somebody can be
interesting content but you know I'm
doing instruction so that's one source
and another source is a now art critic
for the nation our third and Tonto but
before he became an art critic danto is
an analytic philosophers of history and
danto sets up a problem
narration and knowledge or actually the
book is called analytic analytical
philosophy history in the chapter that
I'm interested in is called narration
and knowledge as chapter 8 of this book
there is written in 1960 he sets up an
interesting problem that released for me
was interesting he imagines a world in
which there was an ideal chronicler of
events or an ideal chronicle of events
so that every event that ever happened
just as it happened as it happened was
recorded and then in pieces imagine if
there was such a chronicle of events
just this long list of events and would
that will impact would that have on the
distorting scrap Don so comes to the
conclusion which is right there would
have no impact whatsoever about this on
the historians crap because there's
stories craft is not about the discovery
of things in the past it's about the
it's about writing a particular kind of
narrative account that and folks
something he calls a narrative sentence
which is a sense that that refers to
something in the past by a standpoint in
the future so for example the classic
narrative sentence on Christmas Eve 1642
the father of modern physics was born
and of course that sentence couldn't be
true until modern physics was born and
that by the way that's Newton's so
Newton was born on Christmas Eve 1642
but this sentence of Christmas Eve 1642
the father of modern physics was born
couldn't have been written until modern
physics important that's the historians
problematic is that is is is writing
sentences like that which then tells you
that the past is activated by the future
that historians crap what it is about
history is standing somewhere in the
future producing the elements in the
past that we're going to array through
narrative sentences to 22
to tell a story about how we got to
where we are and then contemporary
philosophical orientations or in-store
clinicians the future can end it in the
organization of the choices of what
sentences weren't chooses to write that
is the facts one chooses to dredge up
are things that we call standpoints I'm
a FEMINIST on the socialist that
standpoint that allows me to select just
those facts and I write in the story
this is a problem I've been interested
in for a long time which is which is how
how could we tell stories that were not
restricted to just a single standpoint
and maybe someone you've seen the movie
Rashomon mushroom on as a japanese movie
there's a rape this the movie is told
it's a little bit of the older version
of shortcuts i guess but anyway it's a
more sophisticated version this story is
told from four from four simultaneous
from four points of view for different
people to the story it's not the blind
man in the elephant it's not that one's
on the tail and ones on the head so it's
not that they see different things they
see they share the same events but they
array the events of different sequences
and if you read genesis by the way
you'll realize Genesis has for
storytellers the stories or a raid and
different secret the elements are all
overlapping and the whole thing is
different than what could be revealed by
one or another of these people so what's
been interesting to me as a world
historian also as a sociologist ish how
to free ourselves from standpoint so
that we could see the pass from multiple
points of view simultaneous now those
are the introductory comments to what's
my project and after I talk about what
my project is then we'll talk about
yours which is obviously more
interesting
by the way I'm often abstract and I'm a
little bit like a dog that um that um
well I don't feel like a dog but anyway
when you think what you watch dogs do
this weird thing right before they lie
down or poop I guess they walk around in
circles on their understood why they do
that aha sells huh I don't know quite
what the motivation is but anyway I know
that that I'm also will do this a little
bit in talk so you know if any point
seems like you're lost is in trouble I
think we do we declare the grass in the
field before they lay down well see your
impunity motive on the basis of intro
yeah that's what a verdict huh yeah well
it's possible but we we gave them that
motive yeah it makes no sense just to I
don't want to look at lost here but you
make a circle right they don't lie down
in a circle they in fact they lie time
in inside the circle so you're not
clearing anything so how would that
theory by bed yeah so I believe that I
don't know how to make this thing work
yeah try it try the left hand thing
somebody knowledge oh yes oh okay and
now you'll never get back if you put the
back and forward case I said it doesn't
matter now I think some of you already
seen this to bill right I mean that's
the other thing I don't want go or
something build it and you make maybe
everything I've done bill is already
done so i can just do the super quickly
right two seconds so a few slides ago
well the thing that I don't know how
bill teaches this work so that's always
a mystery to me why niches and how it
teaches it but the problem that this
work addresses it's becoming and can so
I'll do it super quickly since you've
seen it although not all of yours yet
and and and what we've done here in this
project is for a single narrative which
is this paper but we have think 60
some-odd narratives translated actually
upstairs if somebody could do this with
they felt like it and there another 586
that someone could do with it these are
stories that were written in nineteen
August 1934 right both right after the
nazi seizure of power about how people
became a Nazi how did joined the nazi
party and it was a little it's a funny
it's a it's a story that was part of a
contest that was sponsored by the SS so
you know you need to know all the things
that are contaminating that the
production of the material and it's um
and the about i think 600 people
submitted stories about how they became
a nazi and the stories are written by
people who are the early joiners of the
Nazi Party that as they joined the four
nineteen thirty and and there are one in
four hundred sample of the early joiners
and the people who if you follow their
subsequent careers if they weren't into
brown shirts and just about to get wiped
out which is half
these people they rose to help positions
of quite remarkable power so these are
very early stories of adherence of the
Nazi Party written as as a contest for
the best story so what we did with these
stories is we transform them into graphs
and the the logic of trying to transform
them into graphs was to was to try to
capture a structure of the narration of
becoming so that we can identify
elements in the becoming process that
were central to their own cognition
again this is their theory of how they
became a Nazi so it's there they're
quite purposely thinking that end point
of the story is how i became a nazi
they're telling that story they're
theorizing it and they're selecting from
their past events that that that they
wanted to array just in that order to
tell a compelling story and now this is
a little sub sub slot of the graph it so
it's a little a little sequence of
events I believe that our boy is
describing a situation where his mom
buys him a pair of brown pants she
doesn't know the significance of the
brown pants he feel he will he
recognizes the significance of ground
pants he wears them proudly to school as
he's going to school he has a cognition
I feel like half a Nazi he goes to
school he gets in a fight with two
Jewish kids he punches them in the nose
he gets expelled from school and he
returns home and so this little element
of the narration is built as a graph
where the narrative itself allows us to
draw an arc between of an events in the
past or the future to an event in the
past or the future that is that the next
event couldn't have happened without the
prior one so it's it's the author's own
imputation of cause al causal logic and
the story and this is
this is done by hand without any
sophistication and there's no attempt to
be scientific which i always think is I
think it's a waste of time but if you
wanted to try to be scientific you could
use programs that are designed to do
this for you f know is one there are a
bunch of programs that basically set up
a series of counterfactual so you could
ask you know you can ask you can
undertake a counterfactual experiment in
order to ascertain whether you would
draw an arc from one node to another and
and and that's scientifically legitimate
it gives you a language a program and so
on but I don't I didn't do that and it's
not that I'm a Luddite I just I just
can't see any value but there is value
in getting secure so if it gives you
security you should do it I doubt you
know I should I probably shouldn't say
these things but you know anyway a lot
of a lot of programs that are just you
know they're like blankets you know if
you could be useful and if you need them
they're great in a lot of people like
those blankets so they'd like you to use
them so that's one of the problems of
disciplinary side today we produce a
graph that that is built off the micro
elements of a narrow narrow you go to
the next slide and then we can represent
the entire structure of that single
story as a network and subjected to
network analysis techniques and the idea
there is that by subjecting the network
analysis techniques who can we're going
to look at the entire object at one
moment and ask questions about that
object is what's its structure what's
the central node what holds it together
one of the pieces that that one would
need to remove to break up the story and
what does it look like as a graph in
general and and our idea at the time was
that the analysis of the structure might
reveal something about something about
the theory of becoming that is not in
individuals cognition so that one of the
things that I am interested in this the
limits of individuals theorizing and I
believe like a true structuralist that
that people might might have a
structural theory of something that that
emerges even if they can't articulate
that structural theory is selecting this
content over that content that but
what's really driving it is is a
theoretical framework and that's where I
was interested in coming here this graph
shows that if you look over time from
the left to the right there's a there's
obviously a different structure here
that's going on this there's the
becoming story that are deeply
intertwined deeply theorized deeply
connected you can move from any given
point to any other given point it's a
very coherent story and then at the
point that they transition to being a
Nazi which I think of the stories of
that 139 what happens it's just action
an action without narrative so there's
no continuity in the structures just one
event after another and the self is lost
so our idea in this illustrative paper
was to say you could use narrative
network methods to understand the theory
of becoming what's up what's what's
driving it and then to understand
something about what what's become and
that traditional theory of the coming if
you ask people to tell them your if you
ask people tell you their life story
they will tell you a story that's an
assemblage of events and people so the
self emerges from the accretion of
people on to you and the accretion of
social relations on to you and an
assemblage of experiences and that's
what we tell people we tell people how
we we emerge in the context of a
population of other people parents
friends lovers children and so on that
self that emerges is is relationally
rich and Nazi stories and stories of
Alcoholics Anonymous and stories of
people who are born again and a number
of other a number of other stories of
people who will become take on a master
identity that is an identity that trumps
all other identities are typically still
as a religion Malaysia so rather than
the self being emerged appearing from
the appreciative persons that emerging
from the illusion of persons and the
little story about the nut little boy
getting into fight he feels like half an
ounce if he gets in a fight he gets
expelled from school so he loses his
school relations and his narrative is a
narrative of loss there's a fantastic
narrative of a mother who her story is
the progressive slot death of her
husband and then four children at the
hands of the Social Democrats and Street
in street battles the Social Democrats
killed there are lots of street battles
I mean that the Nazi seizure of power
was believe it or not contested and and
the Social Democrats killed this family
and and after each death she feels you
know closer to being a Nazi and and and
her story is a story of just to complete
loss of the family so anyway this is to
reveal a renting idea that the Nazi is
just an actor solace selfless after just
action without action without people and
that then what it means to be Co not to
you is to just act in go to the next
slide I'm going to try to speed up and
then this price this is wasted wasted
time very excellent oh okay that's fine
well bit slide the weakness I don't
think you can go backwards okay okay
well let's go forward good fully okay so
I had done the slides that we're
skipping over rapidly or slides that try
to count out what's driving the element
with respect to what's the
characteristic of the event through the
cognition is it a macro level of ethics
exageres to the actors at a micro level
event that's endogenous to their own
life experience it makes an argument
about the particular placement of
cognitive events is driving the
narrative at particular moments of time
and and that's the closest that one
could I can get to prop which is this
ordering of cognitive advances as as
well as the elements that are that are
producing a narrative and this this
slide then says well we can color we can
color advance by by themes and we can
then ask the question like how central
is that theme to the narrative as a
whole and and then here we can identify
some themes like chaos exposure to Nazis
anti-semitism then beam of order and so
on and we can try to we can try to
discover that that some kinds of themes
turn out to be have greater centrality
and by centrality the network I'm
thinking about the note that if you took
it out the rest of the thing would fall
apart so in this particular narrative
and actually in the narratives in
general this tension between chaos and
order is the most central trope that's
used and so it's the thing that occupies
this the core of the narrative and it
drives it for it so you take it out the
coloring process is lost and the
mechanism then is this exposure to
knotts you sir so the story is typically
our experience of chaos the recognition
of ordered that contact with a Nazi and
these are the elements that hold the
whole thing together and you know what's
missing is anti-semitism and that could
either because it's canonical you know
so present that you can't even tell a
story about it which must be the case or
or they don't even theorize it
design theorizing balazs it's can't even
be deployed I guess that's the same
thing because it's such a canonical
experience so one of the limits of this
is that you can't distinguish between
the canonical experience that can't be
told because it's so routine because you
can't tell a story of something that's
just always there and the eventful
demands of narration the narration
demands events you've populated with
things that happen and if something is
canonical that is it simply can't be
told because it's always the same you
may never get it from the life history
the canonical example I guess is you
know you're driving down the highway and
you see your car behind you and you look
in the rearview mirror it's still there
it's still there the ever rarely does
that car you know fly above you and you
know if it did you know elevate up and
fly and hover above you you tell that
story but it's really always just behind
you and so there's no story that you can
tell it's a boring story who said while
I was driving there's a car battery I've
looked again in a car with my so it
demands a narration then also select on
things happen that was that good in
excellent so this project i think was it
was a failure in the sense that it we've
done well the idea was to try to
describe a becoming process and and i
think we succeeded in describing a
strategy for that but it failed it
failed because we we didn't solve a
class of really difficult problem so for
how to how to how to compare processes
across many different people
that was that this is a second project I
do you do this in bill Scott's thank
goodness there's a much more interesting
project so there's a little Chinese
village called me loom and near all the
people in li long and um and oil
historian went into me look any took
life histories of the villagers and the
little dark people are those people the
dark little circles here are the people
that we took life histories from and the
Chinese village is organized into
different clans and families and this
slide is supposed to convince you that
this is a representative sample of the
population of lelu with with respect to
who was living their clans and so on and
so this is the story of me Lou go to the
next slide he took like books we took
like life histories and I did the same
thing with the life histories as i did
with becoming a Nazi that as I I
transform these life histories of the
grafts and this slide is supposed to
indicate that that people are better or
worse theorists and that um that some
people have very thin lines very thin
thin we told stories and in my logic
there very powerful theorists so
ordinary people who have a thin
narrative you know that just goes boom
boom boom boom boom boom but without all
these experiences are very powerful
fierce they're telling the story of
their life they got it all lined up so
one of the hallmarks if we look at
alcoholics anonymous as you learn how to
become an alcoholic as you learn how to
tell the alcoholic story to get to the
point where all you are is an alcoholic
the story becomes thinner and thinner
and thinner until it reduces its form to
I was always an alcoholic you know and
everything that happens in the alcoholic
life is the consequence of that single
fact so the narration the demand of the
powerful theory of i dint of becoming an
alcoholic which is directly
an alcoholic and all your relations and
everything and always work is the
production of a very powerful theatre so
this is to indicate that they're thin
and thick theorists and that one of the
beautiful things about people in general
that they're not as powerful theorists
as historians or sociologists or
alcoholics and that when they tell life
stories you know they kind of jiggle
around and lots of things are seemingly
unconnected to other things so in this
life so I hear you know there's just a
bunch of events that just are told they
don't have any relationship to anything
else but this is a more powerful
theorists there's a bunch of little
things in the past they don't make any
connection but at a certain point you
know you can get from any point in this
graph down to the end of this story
which is somewhere down here so there
are people who are more powerful as
fearsome us so I'm going to use these
people as my Raja moths and that's what
I'll do miss is I have 14 of these life
boys and like you used to do in sixth
grade or fourth grade you might have
made transparencies and stuck them on
top of each other you can go to the next
one and that looks and eager yeah yeah
and if you stack the stories up on top
of each other you can produce and a
complete inventory of everything that
ever happened to this village and that's
what's done here so this is a all every
single event that ever occurred in this
low ability of lelu from the 14
storytellers there about 2,000 of them
that some of these events are shared
they share the same event so we identify
the same event and then we say because
we've stacked them on top of each other
then whom they are intelligent and you
can see that there's this gigantic core
of shared events that in a giant
component that's completely interrelated
that everybody sort of locks in on as as
as they all produce from their
standpoints so the other thing I'm
tibias each of these people there's like
a feminist a socialist or communist
whatever their standpoint there Stan
Pines their life but they're they're
telling the story of their life and it's
producing this this intersection of
incredible dense objects and there's a
million other things going on and my
idea is I'm going to tell the story of
this village and these things happen but
there's a part of some other history
they're not the story of Lulu so my idea
is that I'm like a rash amount i'm going
to get i'm going to get the story of
Lulu I'm going to get the story of the
rape from multiple points of view
simultaneous so I'm go to the next slide
and and here there's a whole series of
components and network language of
components is a larger unit that you can
get to from anywhere so if you're in it
you can connect to all the other events
so these are all the different
components there's a big yellow cohesive
component here they're all of your this
event is tied to every other yellow
event but there's some other look here's
a little red component that connects all
these red events and so on so there are
different stories moving on terms of
graphical representation there's not
really time anymore time sort of gone
but there is is dent is depth this is an
event up here that that has only one
event that's behind it and this is an
event down here that has many events
that are behind it so in rough terms
time moves down because time the more
things happen before you the lower
you're going to be but that's not
necessarily true so this is now just an
image of the depth of this history you
go to the next slide and here I'm trying
to say that that actually everybody
contributes in their own special way to
making this story of Lee look so here
the green people this is the green guide
or woman those are her elements and then
the yellow person's elements come in
here this is the brown person it's not
so they're all telling their own stories
and they interrelate with each other to
produce this little history
so it's not that I could I could take
out a single person when I would have a
different object I mean I've produced
this from the multiple points of view
simultaneously okay next slide okay and
then I pretend that I was a historian I
read all of the all of the all of the
history of Leland everything that these
people said and and I told this story of
leader and I'm after telling the story
of Leland I turned my story into a graph
it starts here and goes through here it
ends up here and you can see it's a very
nice historical story it starts with
some events that are very interconnected
has this dense middle part everything is
connected it's a very powerful theory
I'm I told a standard historical story
which is you know basically a story of
poverty impoverishment revolution in the
countryside mal comes in the Communist
come in they take over and then and then
Mouse is this weird thing he says to to
win Yunnan we have to lose you nan and
then the Maoist pull out and then
there's a period of counter-revolution
that guam and down comes in they rape
they pillage they slaughter some of the
land some of the people in the village
give them t welcome them in the farmers
fleet of the countryside there's a
staged war between a stage battle
between them between the Communists and
the japanese is a complicated story
there and then the Communists come back
in a golden sun a golden error appears
so the story is the story of revolution
counter-revolution and revolution in
this village we go to the next slide and
this is the story for as long as anyone
could remember or life as peasants as
hard as hard or starvation there were
superb subversive age
well activity land land owners began to
withdraw to the hills the 8th army came
in many landowners fled the 8th army led
by now began the block it Yunnan they
took over your Don ok then over a decade
later now anticipated the return of the
glow and done the public meeting is
words repeated to the crowd to keep you
now and we have to lose you nan there's
a kind of revolution it goes on so this
is my story of this village constructed
from these people's lives we can claim
the slide and here are some of those
events so that just to see that the real
history is revealed in here when the
command on comes in after the Communists
pull out they make slaughter and pillage
people and in general people put that
struck that event here you know some
people start their story with that their
story starts with the rape of their
mother or their sister and that's their
story and so it's the beginning so some
people put it here let me go to the next
slide so there's things that happen in
books rip the next one alright so in
theory I just just trying to be hey I
could do that for every I could do that
for every event and and if you do a for
every event you realize that that the
events themselves and refract away from
from their chronological position
because of course Google of telling
their own stories so what I've tried to
do in this study that was there was to
try second take out I can take life
stories pile them on top of each other
to tell a collective story that couldn't
be told by anyone it doesn't exist as an
object and then asked questions about
that history that I've told by
transforming it into a structure that we
couldn't otherwise see each individual
at their own sort that the structure is
different and it's different than that
thin historical story that we tell
and by putting it into this larger form
this network of events that are
connected by many many stories you can
actually learn what the key historical
events where that may change well and
that's the work that I've been doing
this got a lot of other pieces to it
this is a young this is a theory
chairman Smith okay so do you know what
this is oh yeah well um this is a trend
of course distance you know it's a
student in mind without teaching at
Stony Brook and got interested by virtue
of work with Mary Marshall Clark in oral
history and by working with me got
interests and networks and had been
doing this phenomenal field work in
eastery of this area look of ethnic of
ethnic tension between the times and
Slavs Easterns and songs and in which
there was the same alteration of ethnic
cleansing regime shift ethnic cleansing
and and and Italians fled East
transflective Italy Slavs were embedded
into the u.s. love into the Antigua
slavia eventually became dominant of
course and and what Tammy did is she she
looked at the oral histories that were
collected by the individuals fleeing
from from this period of ethnic
cleansing that were given given to the
refugee in refugee headquarters and then
she went back and she found these
peoples grandchildren and interviewed
them about their experiences both in
history in Italy and in the newest novel
so she connected the past and the
present through the same generations and
and she then tries to analyze how it is
at these two groups of people actually
they're all also ironic
interesting living in complete harmony
at Coney Island right so it all actually
started I guess in a project of yours
that she went down to Coney Island and
found these people who have thrown each
other's families into Wells all living
together and so that understanding how
that happened this was began this
project but at any rate what she got
what she discovered was this phenomenal
fact that these populations tell very
different stories but but the events
that they tell the stories of are the
same so this notion that that what lies
between competing narrations of the past
as an empty is an empty space of silence
where stories can be told where events
aren't recorded where there's a
demilitarized zone or a desert of
information is certain is something she
does not reveal in fact she reveals at
this border area between the two stories
is the most populated area in terms of
events it's just that because they're
standing in different places when they
look back into the past they grab these
events and then they pull them off
through two connotations to other events
and narrations other that's in
completely different directions so the
most the stories that the most divergent
stories of the Italians and the Slavs
agree on the the shared events but they
deploy them differently the narration is
is the recovery of the past the past is
recovered the recovery of the past the
problem of the recovery of the passes
not do a deal is to reorganize its
narration so I think that's the huge
contribution and this this some says
that the you could capture an important
concept which is the concept of
pepperoni and here we have we have we
have Italian narratives and conceptual
narratives and Slavic conceptual
narratives centering around the sheer
concept so they both this share concept
organises their discursive space in very
similar ways but it's the Cloyd
completely differently
the notion of Pedro neophyte are tied to
notions of harassment of nudists logs
coming of being treated like slaves of
unemployment and for the nudist la
that's how its associated liberation the
occupation invasion so on so they they
take the concept than their juice on the
rhythm of the next slide which are the
coolest yeah so this is the border slide
basically this says if you take all the
Italian narratives and check out all the
Slavic narratives and you do what I did
you stick them all together we produce
this dense region of shared events in
the past that they all agree on that are
deployed completely differently so in
this boundary area between between
narratives of individuals on one or
another side of ethnic cleansing lies
agreement on history but again remember
Madonna said it's an agreement on the
ideal chronicle just the events as they
happen just as they happen which is
meaningless because the what makes
history of course is its connection to
the future which is the narrations that
happen after those events that that pull
them apart and produce two very
different stores so that it is like the
best example I've ever seen of the
problem that Dante's interested in that
the ideal chronicle of events is not
useful because it doesn't tell us what
we care about in terms of historical
understanding which is which is how
things in the past are brought into into
the future through our standpoint this
is my picaresque journey through
narrative history using things that look
like oral history that aren't quite
wrong
but trying to to take narrative
seriously but not get lost in there I
gets stuck in there and the seduction of
narrative but to bring myself from that
seduction just one thing after another
logically unfolding to see what's the
structure of that narration and if
there's another slide I'll talk about
that will fix it that's it thank
goodness five o'clock 45 minutes that's
what I'm interested in I don't know if
that's interested in you I'm dying to
figure out what build us with this stuff
well that's another problem